contrôle des températures lavage des
mains et port du masque dans l'une des
écoles primaires du bidonville de kibera
de la capitale naïrobi les enseignants
et le personnel tente de mettre en
oeuvre les précautions nécessaires au
retour des élèves en classe au kenya
l'année scolaire avait été écourtée en
mars dernier pour les 17 millions
d'élèves inscrits les classes devaient
rester fermés jusqu'en janvier 2021
mais face à la diminution du nombre de
cas de kobe 19
le gouvernement a décidé de rouvrir les
établissements la fermeture des écoles
où sont souvent distribuer des repas
gratuits a eu pour effet d'alourdir les
charges financières des parents
notamment chez les plus démunis
résultat certaines familles n'ont
désormais plus les moyens d'envoyer
leurs enfants à l'école
c'est le cas de cette mère célibataire
de cinq enfants j'ai perdu mon emploi à
cause du kobe 19 le gouvernement a
annoncé l'arrivée retire imminente des
écoles je ne sais pas quoi faire parce
que j'ai encore des arriérés de frais de
scolarité impayés de l'année dernière
mes enfants ont besoin de beaucoup de
choses pour retourner à l'école je ne
pense pas qu'ils puissent y retourner un
jour
si certains élèves vont pouvoir
retrouver les bancs de l'école
permettant ainsi à leurs parents de
reprendre une activité
d'autres vont rester sur la touche avec
pour effet de creuser un peu plus les
inégalités en matière d'accès à
l'éducation
je me sens triste parce que je suis à la
maison tandis que la plupart de mes amis
sont de retour à l'école
c'est triste parce que mes amis
reçoivent une éducation alors que moi
non l'accès à l'école primaire qui
s'étaient considérablement améliorée
dans le pays reste problématique selon
l'unicef au kenya ce sont près de 1,2
million d'enfants en âge d'être
scolarisés qui ne vont pas à l'école